Welcome back everyone it's Pizza time
you probably saw the big announcement
that Marvel just made they're actually
getting ready to bring Sam Raimi on to
do Doctor Strange - it is one of the
greatest possible surprises we could
have gotten this week there's a bunch of
Easter eggs in the announcement it means
a lot of really cool things so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing that infinity
saga box set giveaway for all the movies
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the Sam Raimi spider-man
movies on the video so we'll just break
this down top five style starting with
number five when scott derrickson left
Doctor Strange - a little while ago
Marvel reported that there would be no
delay on Doctor Strange 2's release date
it's supposed to come out at the
beginning of May 2021 next year Marvel
also confirmed that they were still
going to start shooting the movie in the
next few months
meaning they probably already had some
backup choices for directors ready to go
one of my fantasy picks in the video
that I posted for that was Sam Raimi
himself and apparently Kevin Feige still
has him on speed dial because he seems
like he was their top choice it's only
been a couple weeks since Scott
Derrickson announced he left the movie
and he is a great fit for the movie for
several reasons Doctor Strange - is
going to be the first scary quote-unquote
MCU movie pg-13 horror really is what
Kevin Feige is saying and while most of
you know Sam Raimi from the original
Tobey Maguire spider-man movies Sam
Raimi got his start doing indie horror
movies like Evil Dead Evil Dead - army
of Darkness he still makes low-budget
horror films between big studio movies
and there's even a very prophetic Doctor
Strange scene in spider-man 2 that a lot
of you remember is this somehow he
always knew that doing a Doctor Strange
movie or doing Doctor Strange the
character would be in the cards
guy named Otto Octavius
winds up with eight
limbs
what are the odds?
Hoffman!
what are we going to call this guy?
Doctor Octopus and that's
crap. science squid? crap. Doctor Strange?
that's pretty good but it's taken
wait
wait I got it
Doctor Octopus I like it
it's funny how the context for that
scene has changed so much just because
of him coming on to do Doctor Strange -
and if you've never watched any of his
Evil Dead - or army of Darkness movies
those are pretty much horror comedy
movies they're just flat-out great
movies so go watch him this weekend if
you haven't seen him you'll love Bruce
Campbell very groovy number four next
big cool deep cut Easter Egg Doctor
Strange - won't be the first time Sam
Raimi and Kevin Feige have worked
together on a giant Marvel movie because
Kevin Feige helped out on the original
sony spider-man movies you won't find
him anywhere in the behind the scenes
pictures or in the credits because at
that point in his career he was still
pretty low on the totem pole at Marvel
Studios underneath a via rod it wasn't
really until he took over as president
of Marvel Studios and they made Iron Man
1 that Kevin Feige started putting his
name on everything and his presence was
known in a much bigger way he started
being the person in front of the camera
talking about these movies here's a
really good example of early era Kevin
Feige from the set of the very first
x-men movie this movie was released in
2000 but the picture was taken in 1999
over 20 years ago now baby Kevin Feige
working on the Marvel movies is just
that they're all Marvel movies being
made by other Studios at that point we
also learned recently that when they
started making the modern Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies the infinity
saga Kevin Feige did have a plan to
crossover Tobey Maguire's spider-man
with the Avengers because that was long
before Tom Holland ever entered into
their minds I'll explain that in a
second because they actually released
footage as evidence of that some cool
deleted scenes but it was revealed
during Doctor Strange - that because the
title is literally multiverse of madness
that we'd be seeing alternate versions
of the characters that we know so a lot
of you now have theories about potential
for a Tobey Maguire spider-man cameo
maybe even Bruce Campbell or Ted Raimi
his brother or at the very least some
Easter eggs for Sam Raimi's spider-man
movies because the joke is Sony has
already been trying to do that tie all
the spider-man movies together in the
venom verse and then tie that to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe inside the
Morbius trailer so number three Sony's
attempt to crossover with the Marvel
movies we were talking about this when
they first dropped the Morbius trailer
the trailer itself is the combination of
three different
choices the venom verse movies because
of the Morbius character is a direct
venom spin-up Tobey Maguire's spider-man
movies which Sony made because of the
specific spider-man costume
this is Tobey Maguire spider-man costume
the Tom Holland Marvel spider-man movies
because of the graffiti blaming him for
the death of Mysterio at the end of
spider-man far from home and again with
the marvel spider-man movies because of
the Michael Keaton vulture cameo scene
wearing his same prison uniform from the
spider-man homecoming post-credit scene
so we're all wondering now if they're
going to let Sam Raimi reference his
spider-man movies and then we can say he
exists in the multiverse in a different
universe but Sony is laughing because
they kind of already did that maybe you
remember Amy Pascal even tried to
explain it this way when they were
promoting spider-man homecoming remember
the funny meme interview of Kevin Feige
reacting to Amy Pascal all uncomfortable
she's trying to explain how the
spider-verse venom movies will loosely
be connected to the MCU movies through
the spider-man Tom Holland character we
adjunct to it they may be different
locations but it will still all be in
the same world and they will be
connected to each other as well so it's
clear watching that clip from a couple
years ago the Kevin Feige wasn't totally
sure about how all this Spiderman
multiverse crossover stuff would work so
he's squirming a little bit because he
doesn't want to say something
prematurely before they'd figured
everything out I've already done a few
spider-man videos about how that Tom
Hollands spider-man crossover stuff is
going to work with the Marvel movies
with the Sony spider-man and venom
movies it sounds more complicated than
it is so I'll link that video in the
description number two the Wandavision
trailer is just the beginning of big
multiverse Doctor Strange 2 story based
stuff in that trailer they reference
expanding the Marvel Universe is
speaking of the new Disney Plus Avenger
stuff they're doing like look at all the
cool stuff we're doing with the movie
people on Disney Plus but it's also a
clever meta reference to the expanding
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe through
the multiverse is a story device which
we can speculate about x-men characters
Fantastic Four venom crossovers but last
summer at comic-con Marvel and Kevin
Feige revealed that the multiverse is
the next big story device that they're
going to lean on heavily during Marvel
phase 4
whereas before during the infinity saga
it was the Infinity stones now it's all
about threats from the multiverse that
all
kind of gets into what's going on in the
Loki trailer footage from the weekend
I'll be doing a video for that too
because it's really cool but
Wandavision and Doctor Strange two are the
first places we'll see them confronting
that head-on the number one this is
really cool
the original plan for crossing over
Tobey Maguire's spider-man with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies so
recently you recall Marvel released a
deleted scene from the first Ironman
post-credit scene as part of the
Infinity Saga box set it was an
alternate version of the Nick Fury
post-credit scene where he's telling
Iron Man about the Avengers initiative
except in this version of the deleted
scene he references spider-man and x-men
by name
as if it gamma accidents, radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't enough,
I have to deal with a
spoiled brat, who
doesn't play well with others and wants
to keep all his toys to himself
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury director of shield I'm here to
talk to you about the Avenger initiative
Well, what are we avenging?
whatever the
hell we want.
so radioactive spiders and
mutants they did the scene that way
because Kevin Feige always had plans to
try and cross spider-man over with the
Avengers and the x-men characters but at
the time that they filmed this scene
they didn't have deals in place with
Sony or Fox to share any of those
characters which is why they had to cut
it out of the movie the reason why the
spider-man referenced in that scene is
Tobey Maguire's spider-man is because
when they did this scene it was a long
time before Sony ever recast spider-man
as Andrew Garfield that didn't happen
until 2010 like look at the date in this
announcement
Iron Man 1 came out in 2008 so at the
time Tobey Maguire was still spider-man
and Sony still had plans to make
spider-man 4 then obviously a couple
years later Sony changed their mind
decided to completely reboot that
franchise with Andrew Garfield but let
me know in the comments if they let Sam
Raimi reference his spider-man movies
and Tobey Maguire in some way what do
you want that to look like remember keep
your expectations low I don't actually
think Tobey Maguire is going to have a
cameo see
during Doctor Strange too but it's really
easy for them to include an easter egg
for his spider-man if they're already
going to be showing us different
versions of other characters from the
multiverse I'm going to go to the store
I'll be back in 20 minutes
alternatively we could order a pizza
Pizza time
thanks I can't just drop out of square a
little dangerous audience see it chump
what'll happen next is is I'll be doing
my Loki trailer video it is a whole
bunch of really cool multiverse stuff
that they're setting up in multiverse
villains so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see that
video when I post it every one click
here for my Wandavision trailer video
and click here for that new Falcon in
Winter Soldier trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay awesome it's
Pizza time!